we had this video from uh Chuck kolesto
it's a video of a guy uh let's see if is
the audio gonna play
so I don't I don't know the audio coming
through give it to me Chuck
no Auto's not coming through at all but
uh I'll just explain for you simply put
no it's just not coming through for you
I'm not seeing it on the I'm not hearing
it I'm not hearing it either and it's
not coming up on the thing
yeah so the audio audio is not playing
but that's fine that's fine there's a
video of a guy who's a distributor he
works for an affiliate company he says I
want to make sure I clarify that he's
got Bud Light on his arm at a liquor
store now this could be fake you know I
just want to make sure that's clear like
hard to verify just a random video on
the internet but this is just one of
several videos I've seen of people in
similar situations pointing out that
this the shelves are loaded with
Anheuser-Busch products and this guy
says that he works for an affiliate
company that only sells bud and Bud
Light products and he's never seen sales
this low which worries him because if we
don't sell these products I don't feed
my family like this is my company like
that I work for we got to do this yeah
and he goes so uh thanks Anheuser-Busch
maybe I won't I won't feed my family I
definitely think it's a little
hyperbolic but we've seen a bunch of
these videos where people are reporting
on the ground that sales are dropping
we've seen the stock dropping and I
think it lines up and I think this
the left operates on lies and
manipulation I shouldn't say I don't say
all the left I want to say the woke cult
operates on lies and manipulation and so
they will twist anything as a victory
and they will twist anything you say
into something negative so here's what I
have to say
I'll be fully honest maybe these videos
are being faked by people who want to
make it seem like we're winning but I'll
just take it I look at their stock
prices their stock prices are way down
yeah so that's an independent metric
whereas the videos are not but all but
you know what if the stocks are dropping
and there's rumors of sale Decline and
then I see these videos I'm more
inclined to believe that these and other
videos I've seen are probably true
there's there's one video where it's
just a guy standing in a supermarket and
he just pans left and right and then you
see all the beers gone and then he pans
over and all the Budweiser products
still look we're in Austin why don't at
some point I'll go to a supermarket
Center why don't we just go to a
supermarket do it ourselves
yeah because I wonder if how pronounced
it is in a place like Austin yeah right
so so here's the other thing we're
hearing the guitar player from The
Offspring he countered Kid Rock and he
was like we're gonna stock all of our
shows with Anheuser-Busch products to
counter the bigots
it's like okay I mean this is
it is a bit silly I suppose but hey it's
a culture War for a reason I mean using
a guy that claims to be transgender to
sell your beer is a bit bigoted they're
like using Dylan Mulvaney it's not like
it's even worse to to use a guy to Mark
her tampons and sports bras
yes it's like using his identity it's so
just underhanded dirtiness to sell
product here's what I think I'll tell
you what I think
Tick Tock my personal opinion is it's
not real my opinion has never been that
my opinion has always been that it's not
real and uh my opinion Tick Tock bite
dance whatever so I said this a few
years ago I explained how a new social
media platform can emerge and I've
actually talked to tech companies about
this here's what you do create an app
then Market that app on Instagram
Facebook or wherever to uh teenagers say
the new cool app to do this thing hire a
bunch of young people to do a fun thing
like uh you know singing songs then when
they download it and they make a post
give them 150 likes give them 50 new
followers they're going to respond to
that positive reinforcement and they're
going to be like whoa I got a bunch of
new followers
you give them fake followers and
eventually all of these kids are going
to be like you still use Instagram
that's so lame why aren't you using you
know glabo and they're gonna be like
what what's that you're not on glabo
dude I Got 5 000 followers and then the
friend is gonna go you're 5 000
followers yeah I'm a big deal they're
gonna feel real good even though there's
no real humans behind that number but
that will convince their friends to get
on the platform as well you know what's
terrifying to me about that by the way
what's terrifying to me is I have
thought over the last few years that so
many things were conspiracy theories
that turned out to be not conspiracy
theories like all of them and now now
I'm listening well that's what what
happens when you're looking at it from
the other end of history and now I'm I'm
hearing this and I'm thinking you know
that's completely feasible yeah
especially with uh Quantum Computing on
the horizon and artificial intelligence
you could have a hundred thousand
followers that aren't real people that
are commenting actual things in response
to what you're doing yeah the
governments have been doing this for a
very long time I think the Israeli
government was the first one to come
come out about it publicly where they
described whole entire factories of
people that were online digital troll
armies that were specifically making
sure that they were engaging in debate
and conversations that made the Israeli
government look good Joe Biden just
announced a whole campaign for online
influencers that are going to be his
influence Army for the next 2024
presidential election so obviously
they're paying for PR using our tax
dollars to have people show for them who
are just saying and doing anything for a
buck Dylan Mulvaney was one of them yes
and then wait wait hold on Joe ba I saw
this story this is the 50 Cent Army for
the Democrats yes and delmovania is
going to be I don't know if he's a part
of it he was an Army he was he went to
the White House but as we know like
Hillary Clinton hired influencers high
level influencers even someone I don't
think yes to specifically endorsement
hold on was he hired by them there's
different ways that of course they
conduct their businesses through Pacs
and different organizations so we have
to be careful with exactly how we're
wording here but I think it's fair to
say that money exchanged hands for the
support of this particular candidate
that money coming from of course either
super Pacs or our connections
organizations that's a bold but when you
have no no no no no no in terms of Casey
neistat this one matters he was he's the
biggest vlogger he's not really doing as
much content as he used to he came out
and endorsed Hillary Clinton it is my
personal opinion that likely constituted
a monetary exchange from someone or
somehow because I don't see how you get
a dude who like films drones and
longboarding and and talking about
filmmaking all of a sudden coming out
and endorsing a politician in an
election but is entirely possible he's
just going along with the crowd and
that's that's why it ended up happening
it might be connected or not connected
but how much was the CNN deal that's
also another one that also has a lot of
people looking at the situation like how
much money did he make what did he do
that I don't think he failed the whole
thing didn't do anything so there's
multiple ways of of having people show
but for the spider Administration to
openly kind of discuss how they're going
to be
taken and giving money to people to
chill for them I mean that's going to
make everyone question like wait are you
really in support of this person or are
you just being paid to support this
person look I I
when I go out into normal places you
know if you're in DC you're going to be
around a bunch of people who are hyper
political but when I go out to the
movies when I go to pool pool halls when
I go to the poker club or whatever I
have not met a single person who was Pro
Biden
like pro-democrat I don't see them
anywhere and you know of course if I say
something like that I'm gonna do a bunch
of leftist being like haha go touch
grass but like dude
I've not seen it anywhere I you know I
go I go to uh we've been going to
Maryland Live a casino
playing uh Hold'em one two super super
inexpensive for those that that are
considering playing it's like you pay
Two Bucks play a hand so it can be
played cheaply and uh
out of all the tables I've played at and
this is north of DC south of Baltimore I
have not met a single pro Democrat
person in this major urban center where
it's just regular people hanging out
from various ages young guys to older
guys well how do you know does it come
up at the table absolutely every time
every time without fail someone mentions
the cost of the game or the economy and
then immediately oh Joe Biden Joe Biden
he's bad don't get me wrong I met a guy
who said he thought the j6 or should be
executed and he hated Donald Trump dead
I get but I've not met anybody who was
like I like this guy now that could be
these people voted for him and now they
really really do regret it is it a blue
area it's the bluest is Blue can be
I mean it's it's we're talking about
Baltimore and Maryland and and uh this
casino is I think it's I don't know what
city it's in it's it's 30 minutes from
downtown Baltimore it's like half an
hour from DC or both right in between so
everybody who's going there it's people
from the cities who are trying to you
know play a game or whatever
so I I I I kind of feel like at this
point the the reasoning for why Biden's
building a 50 Cent Army is fairly
obvious I do not see them being able to
pull off another Victory I'm seeing all
these polls where they're like Biden is
beating Trump in these states Biden is
beating Trump and I'm like don't care
don't believe it I mean look ballot
harvesting may come to save the day but
it's clear that they're going to be
ramping up what I would describe as
unethical and malicious tactics in the
election and the idea of of a Democrat
so so for those who don't know the 50
Cent Army what is it in China anybody
who Pro posts on social media Pro CCP
propaganda they get paid 50 cents every
time they do or something like that
so this is basically what we're gonna
start seeing with Democrats and that's
probably what's already happening so
we're talking about anheuser-boys we're
talking about Dylan Mulvaney in the
algorithmic manipulation
that is what the Democrats are riding
that wave
yeah the the thing you didn't say which
I think needs to be said which speaks to
your point is what this does to the
Integrity of the system overall this is
what causes legitimacy crisis right so
we don't trust our institutions we now
think the people we like on social media
they're being paid certain I've never
taken a single penny for anything my
Twitter feed anything I think that that
compromises the Integrity but when you
do that in a political level it's
terrifying to me
it's terrifying absolutely and
especially when you connect it to
something like a social credit score
which they do in China because if you
complain about the government in China
you of course get downranked with your
social credit score you can't get
high-speed internet you can't travel on
airplanes you have you can't buy first
class tickets on trades and that's being
tested in China which they're trying to
roll out and bring out here in the
United States as there's already a
corporate social credit score that no
one really likes to talk about and it's
not a government institution but the
corporate social credit score and
everyone here already exists there is an
ESG score with the corporations but
there's even another one with each
Citizen and civilian with all of your
private records especially from social
media being uh compiled together and
then soon going to be used against you
later what's that called is that a
program they're doing no there's many
different corporations keeping private
records and they sell all these private
records about you and your itinerary and
what you do and what you like what you
dislike your views your opinions all of
that is databased so there's huge
databases being built about particular
individuals those again are are being
used by the corporations they're being
used by the government women in China
and then that's where they're testing
the 15-minute cities so if you say
something bad well your 15-minute City
might be a five minute City and they're
already locking down grids they're
already testing it they're doing a trial
run of that in the United Kingdom
there's a lot of crazy stuff Honolulu
explain the difference what is 15 minute
what does five minute mean well this is
the restrictions that they're setting up
pretty much essentially prisons pretty
much essentially lockdowns they did this
in China and they tested it during covid
they locked out entire communities
because they said they had a positive
case but what a lot of people are saying
that this was most likely a larger test
to see how these 15-minute cities would
work because they would lock down entire
neighborhoods and say you're going to be
you can't move between this street and
this street you can't go between here
and here they tested it out in Australia
where people were fined and arrested for
going from one city block to another
city block because they were going
through an imaginary line in
jurisdiction so a lot of people say that
there was a dry testing of this larger
concept which is essentially prison
grids internal systems where you can't
move around anywhere but 15 minutes
within it and you get everything you
ever wanted right the idea is that
within 15 minutes of your home you can
get access to anything you would need
correct yeah hospitals supermarkets
entertainment movies whatever it is it's
all confined here and you better not go
around this is again to de-insentivize
people from driving do you incentivize
people for having personal Liberty track
trace and database of society of total
control grid the world of information
knowing every little thing about you and
then that information being used against
you in every way and if you're not a
part of the 50 Cent Army well your your
ability to move around is going to be
limited a lot more because the
checkpoints are already there they're
digital and they have cameras and and
facial recognition and all right they're
setting it up
I just wanna I wanna say something you
know there's a viral video we talked
about it's really funny it's where a guy
says he wants to show you a perfect
example of a 15-minute scene how it
works and then he walks up this little
shed and he says let me show you a 50
Cent sitting when he opens it up
chickens and he goes welcome to a
15-minute City he walks inside and says
here the citizens have everything they
could hope for now they could go outside
if they want look the door's open they
don't want to leave it's safe in here
there's no danger they have food they
have water it's always there for them
and then he walks into another room and
he goes you see this instead of grabbing
eggs and he goes they make these and I
take them from them but that's okay
they're happy because they're safe in
their 15-minute City so he made a really
great point and I want to make a point
on top of that could you imagine if you
went to your chicken coop one day to
collect chickens and a bunch of roosters
pulled out guns and pointed them at you
and said you're not taking the eggs this
time you'd be like what how did these
chickens have guns and then you go I'm
like we gotta take these guns away well
we can't like the chickens have guns and
you're like I don't know how they're
even using them and then you got to
figure out how do you disarm the
chickens if if they're armed and they
can fight back you can't take for them
you can't imprison you can't control
them they can they're unequal footing
with you obviously chickens don't have
guns my point is if someone is trying to
control you and you have the means of
telling them no they cannot Implement
their authoritarian fascist takeovers
and that's what we've seen throughout
history when despots and fascists try to
take over yeah guns make it very
difficult that was one of the impetus of
the an emphasis of the Second Amendment
you know and that's why they're doing
this in China they did this in China
they're doing this in the United Kingdom
they did this in Australia during copen
right now in Oxford specifically in the
United Kingdom they're doing the trial
run for the 15-minute cities blocking
people from traveling one road to
another all in the name of
sustainability it's not sustainability
it's enslavement sorry go ahead no I was
just going to say if you look at the
world economic economic performance that
are the data it's not framed as a
conspiracy it's not framed to manipulate
to control it's frame to be sustainable
that's the approach that they use it's
sustainable to have farm animals to
treat human beings like they have no
dignity no individual human spirit and
they can't live on their own then they
need to be dictated what they can and
cannot do or believe in or think and
that's essentially this larger notion
this larger elitism of individuals
thinking that they have the right and
they're they're doing this in so many
instances that are so bastardized that
are so disgusting they think that they
have the right to to control what goes
into your head to control what you see
what you hear and they're doing this
with big Tech social media already in so
many different ways trying to engineer
people to be perfect Lemmings to be
perfect slaves to acquiesce to bow down
and to take it and I think people who
are paying attention had enough of this
bull crap thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time